let's talk about sugar now there's many
different types of sugar I'm going to
show you a couple different types this
is called refined sugar as you may have
already known and what sugar does when
it's refined it's taken out of the sugar
cane and sugar cane naturally has a ton
of vitamins ton of potassium ton of B
vitamins and then we refine it they take
out the all this good nutrition and
that's called molasses okay and they
toss that or they sell it and then they
they this is what they use to put in a
whole bunch of things now there's also
high fructose corn syrup which is very
very cheap sweet sweetener and corn
syrup and we want to stay away from all
that we also want to stay away from this
because when you consume this it
depletes minerals specifically potassium
that's why when you eat something sweet
you fill up with fluid your N equals get
up all puffy and your fingers get puffy
because you're going to retain water why
because this depletes potassium we
already have a problem with potassium I
mean you need 4700 milligrams a day you
don't even get near that and that would
be like 10 bananas so adding this to the
picture is really going to put you in a
situation deplete potassium and B
vitamins and you're going to have
problems with them I mean nightmares and
low blood sugar problems so when the
blood sugar goes down it doesn't mean
eat more sugar okay it means that your
blood sugars are low and that means
you're going to get irritable so try not
to eat and go to a grocery store you're
just going to be thinking about sweets
you're going to be dreaming about sweets
and that's really why people crave
because they have low blood Sugar's now
when the blood sugar goes high you get
tired and sleepy like after you would
eat you might want to just take a nap or
a Thanksgiving meal okay so now there's
different types of sugar right here too
this is natural sugar or it's just
basically sugar with a little bit of
molasses in there okay that's what this
is like
sugar and then we have something else
called turbinado sugar which is raw cane
sugar this is a little bit better than
the other one because it has a little
more molasses and again I'm not telling
you to eat this by the way I'm just
showing you the different types of sugar
this one here is unrefined sugar this is
like molasses crystals it's very earthy
I mean it's the least of all evils I
mean you're it's not that bad if you're
going to eat sugar this would be the
thing you would eat but the thing is
when you make stuff with this you can't
eat a lot of it
because there's so much nutrition it'll
your bio just like okay I had enough
it's very earthy and earthy taste now we
have also honey honey is we're coming up
in the things that are a little bit
better for you even even this the only
reason I would recommend this is coming
off your sugar this would be a little
bit better because this is more of a
diabetic sugar it's called turbinado I'm
sorry side turbinado it's called Tupelo
honey
okay turbinado would be this stuff over
here
Tupelo is a type of honey that is
absorbed very slowly in the body as has
a certain type of sugar because the
little honey bees take 36,000 trips to
the Beehive to make one pound of honey
and then we rip it off and then we give
them the white sugar but if you're going
to do honey to Tupelo Honey and do very
small amounts of it especially with your
kids but it's it goes in very slowly
okay so that would be on the scale of
things it's better than white sugar but
still I would prefer you did our
favorite stevia or fruit like peaches or
bananas that would be even better
if you really need to ask sweetness I
personally don't like sweet sweet any
sweeteners simply because my body is so
used to not eating sugar my taste buds
have adapted and that's what's going to
happen with you once you come off this
sugar for a week or two your taste buds
when you eat sugar it'll be too sweet so
we want to change the way you perceive
in case
people that are used to eating sugar you
eat a lot of it to create the same
sensation so we're trying to get you off
this the sugar but stevia is a really
good thing it's very sweet
put a drop in in anything that you want
to sweeten and it'll be very sweet but
some people don't like this because it's
kind of earthy so you can use the
organic stevia extract here as a powder
form right here don't add a lot there's
it's very very sweet but this is
acceptable sweetener you can have as
much of it as you want now the other
thing about sweets is was hidden sugars
like in vanilla yogurt there's a lot of
sugar in there or flavored yogurt ton of
sugar juice orange juice is a ton of
sugar so you have Rifat you have oranges
and then you refined pasteurized orange
juice which by the way is just like
sugar water and then you have you also
have the vegetable which is not very
sweet has all this fiber and then you
can break it down into vegetable juice
which is that better than that stuff but
it's still sweet you know if you have
like a lot of carrot juice but if you
have celery juice that's going to be
okay so we're looking at the sugar
content we want to lower the sugar
content simply because when you increase
sugar you increase insulin and the
presence of insulin you cannot burn fat
all of the fat burning hormones are
nullified when you have just a little
bit of sugar that means a little bit of
alcohol wine before bed I don't care if
it's white wine or dark wine or whatever
just mix the alcohol right now because
we want to get you off that if you if
you can't get off of it right away then
what you want to do is take that
kombucha tea that I recommend and drink
that instead because it will give you
that same relaxing feeling so we have
orange juice and then we have different
juices that people have and sodas and
things like that with added sugar just
avoid all that stuff I would recommend
eating the whole food and you can blend
it blending your vegetables and fruits
are much much better as compared to a
juicer all right even if it's vegetable
juice so you can take the I mi site I
have all these recipes you can take you
take orange and banana and blend it you
can take kale and and blueberry and
papaya and blend it that would be a lot
better
so what we're trying to do is we're
trying to lower insulin because insulin
is one of the hormones that are negative
and the thing that will stop your
fat-burning hands-down so even that
little bit you know even that little bit
of sugar in your coffee every day even
that little glass of wine before bed
that's enough to blow the whole week so
try to cut the sugar out if you're
craving sweets all that means it's a
potassium deficiency to get rid of
potassium deficiencies what you want to
do is you want to increase your
vegetable to about 10 cups of salad a
day that's what I do
so I have a salad the big salad for
lunch and a big room for dinner it's not
that hard
I mean salads are fluffy you can take
the salad baby green salad and just
compress it into like a little ball and
if you still have problems with that
just take your salad put it in the
blender put dressing put nuts put apples
and blend it you'd be surprised
it's actually quite tasty with a little
bit of grape in there it's delicious
it's like a little coleslaw so those are
some tips I hope you enjoy